Hello, my dear friends, my name is Joulupukki,...
...but I'm also known as Santa Claus,...
...Babbo Natale, Shengdan Laoren, Pere Noel and so on.
Let me tell you about my hometown of Rovaniemi.
Rovaniemi is situated on the Arctic Circle in Laplands.
It is home for many wonderful and nice people.
There are also quite a few reindeer in Rovaniemi.
Rovaniemi is a very beautiful town.
In winter, it's covered with a white curtain of snow...
...and at night, we can see the magical Northern Lights.
Every year, many of my friends from all over the world come visit me.
In Rovaniemi, they feel the true Christmas spirits.
I like to share it with family and friends.
My dear friends, it is my great pleasure to invite you to visit Rovaniemi...